en este vídeo voy a platicar acerca de
triángulos semejantes lo voy a escribir
aquí arriba triángulos triángulos
semejantes
y se me queda un poco fea se me antes y
como en la vida cotidiana como en la
vida cotidiana en la vida cotidiana que
es que dos cosas sean semejantes pues es
que son muy parecidas pero no
necesariamente son idénticas verdad pues
sucede exactamente lo mismo con los
triángulos lo que pasa con los
triángulos semejantes es que son dos
triángulos que tienen exactamente los
mismos ángulos puede que los triángulos
tengan distintos tamaños pero lo que sí
deben cumplir es que tengan los mismos
ángulos entonces déjame tomar el color
amarillo para dibujar un ejemplo voy a
poner por aquí un triángulo que se vea
más o menos así
y de este lado voy a dibujar otro
triángulo que lo voy a poner en color
verde un triángulo por acá
algo de este estilo
bueno imagínate que este ángulo es igual
a éste éste es igual a este y este es
igual a este déjame marcar lo que esté
que este ángulo de acá color rosa voy a
agarrar la herramienta de acá este
ángulo color rosa es igual a este ángulo
rosa de acá que este ángulo de acá
es igual a este ángulo de acá y que el
tercer ángulo también es igual a este
bueno esto ya no hay que pedírselo eso
ya lo podemos deducir verdad porque es
digamos y la medida de este ángulo es x
la de acá también es x si la medida de
este ángulo es la de acá también es y
como la suma de los ángulos en un
triángulo es 180 entonces la medida del
tercero que voy a pintar en azul claro
sería 180 menos x menos y entonces aquí
también le voy a poner que mide 180
menos x menos y menos muy bien entonces
si este ángulo es igual a éste si éste
es igual a éste y éste es igual a éste
si los tres son iguales decimos que los
triángulos son semejantes y eso
básicamente es decir que tienen la misma
forma que simplemente uno es el otro
pero en una versión a escala vale o sea
como que éste lo inflamos sin modificar
su forma o lo desinflamos y entonces
caemos en este d
vale bueno entonces eso es que dos
triángulos sean semejantes y que podemos
hacer cuando dos triángulos son
semejantes pues nos resulta que como
están en la misma proporción si
conocemos las longitudes de los lados de
uno y un lado del otro entonces podemos
acabar de encontrar el segundo triángulo
pero es más fácil de hacerlo que decirlo
entonces déjame déjame hacer un ejemplo
de a qué me refiero imaginemos que el
lado opuesto a este ángulo x es este y
que es este de acá mide 6
vale este de acá lo voy a pintar en
color rosa mide 6 bueno entonces el lado
correspondiente en este pequeño
triángulo es este de acá ahorita vamos a
ver de qué sirve eso
también pensemos que el el lado opuesto
a este ángulo de 180 menos x que es este
de acá que estoy pintando en azul mide 7
entonces en este triángulo el opuesto o
el correspondiente porque es el opuesto
a este mismo ángulo sería este de acá
vale y finalmente a este que voy a dejar
en amarillo déjame ponerle que mide 5
que mide 5 y que éste de acá que es el
correspondiente
ni de dos ni de dos
vale entonces conociendo estas cosas
estas medidas cinco seis siete y esta
medida dos podemos encontrar las medidas
que faltan en este triángulo de acá y
justo tiene que ver porque los
triángulos tienen la misma proporción
entre sí entonces como la proporción de
este lado a este lado es 2 a 5 también
la proporción de este lado a este lado
va a ser 2 a 5 entonces con eso podemos
empezar a encontrar las medidas si este
lado mide digamos a entonces tenemos que
a entre 7 es igual a 2 entre 5 es igual
a 2 entre 5 y de aquí multiplicando por
7 de ambos lados tenemos que a
es igual a 14 entre 5 y 14 entre 5 es
como 2.8 vale entonces a es igual a 14
entre 5 y podemos hacer algo muy similar
con el tercer lado con el que
corresponde al color rosa si a éste le
ponemos b ponemos b entonces ahora b
entre 6 b entre 6 es lo mismo que 2
entre 5 también podríamos poner que 14
quintos entre 7 pero va a salir más
complicado y va a dar lo mismo eso lo
puedes verificar pero déjame hacerlo con
2 entre 5 entonces b en 36 es igual a 2
entre 5 y por lo tanto multiplicando por
seis de ambos lados obtenemos que b es
igual a 12 entre 5 y con eso obtenemos
la medida de este lado de acá que da 12
entre 5 muy bien ya que tenemos esta
idea general de que los triángulos
semejantes están en la misma proporción
vamos a resolver algunos problemas
déjame pasar aquí abajo
voy a pasar aquí abajo para tener más
espacio y pensemos que tenemos dos
rectas paralelas voy a poner una por acá
voy a hacer un dibujo bien grande para
que se vea bonito entonces esas de ahí
son dos rectas paralelas
voy a poner esta flecha que quiere decir
que van en la misma dirección y con esta
y a estas dos rectas paralelas les vamos
a trazar dos transversales una la voy a
poner en color azul
va a venir por acá y la otra la voy a
poner en color rosa que va a hacer algo
de este estilo algo de este estilo vale
no voy a poner un poco más para acá
bueno e imaginemos que conocemos algunas
de las medidas de los lados de estos dos
triángulos observa que al trazar las
transversales se hacen dos triángulos y
vamos a pensar que conocemos algunas
cosas por ejemplo pensemos que sabemos
que este lado de acá que este lado de
acá mide 7 no déjame ponerles 6 mide 6
vale lo voy a poner más grande 6 que
este lado de acá que voy a pintar en
color verde mide 8 este acá vamos a
ponerle que mide 8
8 y finalmente déjame ponerle al de aquí
arriba que mide 5 creo que mi dibujo no
me quedó muy a escala pero bueno no le
hace lo importante es que marquemos los
datos y usamos y usemos eso entonces le
voy a poner que éste mide 5 e imaginemos
que del triángulo chiquito sabemos que
este lado de acá que voy a dejar en
color rosa mide 4
y de 4 entonces a partir de esta
información será posible determinar la
medida de estos dos lados que nos faltan
de este lado de acá y este lado de acá
bueno pues justo la idea va a ser
utilizar que estos dos triángulos son
semejantes pero primero tenemos que
verificar que en efecto lo sean
este triangulito de acá con este
triangulito de acá y más o menos o sea
así a simple vista se ve que este ángulo
va a ser igual a este está igual a este
y este igual a este pero vamos a ver por
qué sucede que esos ángulos sean iguales
déjame empezar con por qué este ángulo
es igual a este de acá esto pasa
simplemente porque son ángulos opuestos
por el vértice
este ángulo con este ángulo de acá son
iguales porque son opuestos a este
vértice si te acuerdas la forma de
justificar eso era que este ángulo más
este de acá lo voy a pintar así punteado
el ángulo sólido más el ángulo punteado
es 180 pero también este ángulo más este
punteado es 180 porque forman la línea
azul la línea azul entonces esté más 780
este más este 180 de modo que éste tiene
que ser igual a este bueno ya tenemos un
ángulo
los otros dos ángulos los vamos a
encontrar en el próximo vídeo utilizando
ángulos alternos internos en paralelas
vamos a obtener que este ángulo este
ángulo de acá es igual a este de acá y
que este ángulo de acá que voy a pintar
en rojo es va a ser igual a este de acá
pero lo vamos a ver en el siguiente
vídeo si quieres mientras repasa un poco
de rectas paralelas para que veas de
dónde sale eso y nos vemos hasta la
próxima